also a good job to everyone who figured
the silence I thought it was be going to
be like complicated I'm sure if you're
watching on twitch you know something
about technology Wow oh dear this is
interesting I'm just trying to absorb
what's happening so we just does
accounting for me that says that blacks
up six let's develop let's develop I
appreciate the creativity okay um
paw and scare me because I can't really
sack this is five plus three so there's
no dirty flagging this is really gonna
be a test of like how it's a rightward
litter its how literate I am with nights
that's not the right word but you guys
know what I mean
because nights sometimes our hearts to
coordinate okay so there's a weakness
but some yeah let's develop if I get
most nights to the third-ranked then
I'll be controlling all the squares on
the fifth rink was this Anaka position I
don't knock a it's a while ago NACA did
streams where he would do these I think
our chests calm like you need you need
an admin to she ha ha ha ha because
horses I want to talk this pawn but if I
had here I get forts
it's probably not a great idea to get
forked putting my
down on this one oh dear not if I put my
hoof down first for my night sir Davina
I'm really not sure what to do like or
how to how to strategize I challenged
you to a position that demonstrates a
bugging Lich's it doesn't adhere to Phi
D rules in what Oh Phi T like feet a
like the world chess interesting Oh that
demonstrates a bug in me chess ooh
well now I'm curious I'm super curious
this problem this position already
doesn't abide to feed a rules because
there's too many nights yeah so I wanted
to do this and target upset but it's not
quite possible get to this might be five
maybe just go after the petition though
I don't know if I want to train this is
so confusing I'm just gonna keep
improving nights there is a rule in
chess it's like a strategic rule where
if you don't know what to do in the
position you should ask yourself what is
the worst place peace and how to improve
it I want you to play is white when I'm
standing challenge which side to put um
before you send a challenge you you
click like the whites the white pieces
there is like on the right side you
should see plaque in the middle it's
random and then on the left its it's
white I believe
okay let's reinforce I kind of have to
trade oh I can win a pawn in the pawn
well twin a pawn
so I was gonna say that if I don't know
what to do I should ask myself like
what's the worst place tonight and how
to improve it but already like there's
becoming things to do like the
especially the dark squares as
probably maybe not the best positional
decision for black to give away the dark
squared bishop because Knights really
like weak squares okay it's also like to
fork these Knights harder or superfluous
I somehow crossed 1700 in bullet today
and now my heart doesn't want me to play
a single joy joy tears of joy well you
should wait what's the same always
listen to your heart or never listen to
you hurts maybe it depends on the
situation I have to retreat g5 let's try
the Knights yeah and I can't move
forward my challenge is really
interesting I promise mm-hmm
maybe next one I'll do random challenge
I'm sure a lot of people are are being
creative so there's also a concept in
chests called superfluous Knights
basically which is two knights that
defend each other in this case a lot of
the Knights are are being superfluous
with one another so I think I can yeah
just go after the Queen I'm just trying
to create a situation where black will
run into trouble
yeah these Knights are also defending
each other so I really don't have to
worry about the Knights that defend each
other this light's not defended well
okay like all these squares are covered
except the square Queen B five would be
a bold move but Queen B five 94-94 is
probably coming regardless because I
want to go after this pawn like
eventually I want to play 94 and 95 use
it our turns
if you want to know what that bug is the
challenge is from de frança well I'm I
am curious and because you're hearing
bits here you're incentivizing me I'll
keep it in mind but there's still work
to be done like black still a material
to be careful these pawns especially
this H farm so I'm gonna first go for
this ensuring that I'm controlling 'if
I've enough times I'm also attacking g5
there might be a situation where I'll
have to sack I can night for couple
pawns
we'll see hmm
so Locke wants to trade these Knights
that move doesn't scare me too much
extra bug incentive normally I would not
be too incentivized to go after bugs but
yeah kiria curiosity is very
incentivizing anyway to figure out I'm
realizing that I probably don't want to
open too many files because under the
rook could actually be a very strong
like the rook is is actually quite
strong against a knight you helped me
enjoy chess with the vids and streams
wish I could convince friends to play
with me thank you okay I need to focus
because there's options here
not sure what to do not sure what to do
I proved the worst place tonight
okay let's improve the worst place
tonight Milan beat one was not doing
anything it was also undefended so it
was very likely that like at some point
there'd be some move like rook being and
I would have to play this anyway so I've
lost a few nights but physicians kind of
simplifying it's hard for the position
to actually simplify because nights are
so confusing it's so good this is hard
to stop what do we do here ninety-three
this is slightly terrifying also thanks
for subbing kid to kid and stars I wish
I could convince friends to play with me
ah well everyone in the chat can be your
friend maybe maybe some people that's
free I'm in Portugal I did a stream
earlier today and there were so many
Europeans thanking me for being European
friendly f-6 so blocks kind of slow
playing let's play night let's play
Knight g4 so one more kind of phenomenon
with Knights like all these Knights are
on light squares which means they only
control dark squares which is probably
good
how the dark squared bishop but these
pawns are are restricting the Knights
yeah let's keep improving at some point
I'm probably just gonna you look like
just jump into e5
oh thanks pam-pam with 711 bits maybe
promoting 7-eleven it's been a while
since I've been to a 7-eleven yeah so my
plan was to just like you my king and
hopefully not get meted spot cave in the
corner
actually if h2 I could just take last
time I was out of 7/11 was probably
Bangkok or Thailand maybe Chiang Mai so
many 7-elevens in Thailand scary
I'm liking 95 like are you have so many
nights I don't mean I can afford to give
away one night I basically sacking a
night for a pawn but the square is so
valuable because once I control it five
then then I have access to Black's weak
spots c 6g 6 that's basically a 4 I
think this would be a fork and this
would be a ford also blocks about 2 flat
okay I'm probably time to start
calculating and like this move
hmm but the King has surrounded my
Knights um wait what's going on here but
I've mate it's so close to me
oh is it meeting - it might be made in -
OH
mm-hmm I think it's it's mate I see four
it's so confusing here here mate Wow for
the finish
I had the inclination that there is
something so I sacked I sacked the first
night on e5 and then I sex this night
and I Drive the King to the center did
all the Knights play a role
all the Knights kind of played some role
I guess I wouldn't need this night
because it's nice also controlling see
fire but most of the Knights did play a
role in that me what a game I was a fun
game yeah that's you - worthy there's no
opening theory to look up hello YouTube
yeah thanks for the challenge inner
greninja also twitch chat is saying hi
to YouTube YouTube say hi to twitch
chats say hi say hi most of you are
probably and maybe the same people but
that's okay you're just people from
different points in time